para que nuestro cuerpo funcione
adecuadamente el ph de nuestra sangre
tiene que estar en un rango muy
específico el pe h de la sangre
sangre tiene que estar en un rango entre
7.35 y
7.45 y si por alguna razón el ph de tu
sangre es menor a 7.35 te van a
diagnosticar aunque bueno esta es una
línea un poco gris pero la comunidad
médica ha definido que si el ph de la
sangre es menor que 7.35 se diagnostica
como acidosis tu sangre está muy ácida
tienes demasiados iones de hidrógeno o
también podemos decir que tienes una
concentración de hidrógeno demasiado
grande en la sangre pero si por otro
lado el p h de tu sangre es mayor que
7.45 se diagnostica con alcohol o sis
carlos is ok porque tu sangre está muy
alcalina se ha puesto demasiado básica
la concentración de iones de hidrógeno
en la sangre o billones de idron ya es
demasiado baja y en estos momentos
puedes decir oye este es un rango muy
pequeño como le hace la sangre para
mantenerse en este rango cuando hay
muchas moléculas ácidas que entran a tu
sangre o cuando hay muchas moléculas
básicas que entran en la sangre como le
hace la sangre para aceptar a todas esas
moléculas y al mismo tiempo mantener su
ph en este rango tan cerrado y la
respuesta está en una cosa que también
es muy útil para transportar el dióxido
de carbono en la sangre tenemos por aquí
unas reacciones en equilibrio tenemos
aquí una molécula de dióxido de carbono
que si ponemos dióxido de carbono en la
sangre que la sangre es principalmente
agua entonces tenemos dióxido de carbono
en una solución acuosa el dióxido de
carbono con el agua va a reaccionar
además de que tenemos en la sangre
algunas enzimas que van a ayudar a que
se dé la reacción pero el punto es que
estas moléculas van a reaccionar para
formar ácido carbónico ok van a
reaccionar para formar ácido carbónico
que es un ácido débil y después el ácido
carbónico se va a disociar en
bicarbonato
bicarbonato y unión de hidrógeno que
como sabemos este guión de hidrógeno
puede reaccionar con una molécula de
agua y transformarse en un millón y
drone eo
y todo esto de aquí para que es útil
bueno como ya dije es parte del proceso
de transportación del dióxido de carbono
en la sangre basándome en las fuentes
que he visto entre el 5 y el 10 por
ciento del dióxido de carbono se puede
disolver en la sangre y después entre
otros 5 y 10 por ciento se puede adherir
a la hemoglobina y transportarse de esa
forma pero el resto del dióxido de
carbono tiene que sufrir esta
transformación a ácido carbónico y
bicarbonato para ser transportado ok de
hecho en la sangre la mayor parte del
dióxido de carbono está en esta forma de
aquí según las fuentes que yo observé
entre el 80 y el 90 por ciento del
dióxido de carbono es transportado en la
sangre en forma de ácido carbónico o
bicarbonato y de hecho se transporta
principalmente en forma de bicarbonato
pero hay que tomar en cuenta que este no
es el tema de este vídeo este vídeo no
se trata de cuál es una forma útil de
transportar al dióxido
carbono en la sangre pero pues esta es
la forma en la que se transporta ahora
de lo que sí se trata este vídeo es de
por qué esto de aquí es útil para
mantener el ph de la sangre en el nivel
adecuado porque estas reacciones en
equilibrio entre el dióxido de carbono
el ácido carbónico y el bicarbonato son
un sistema tampón o también llamado
sistema buffer o sistema de amortiguador
ok este es un sistema tampón y lo que
hace es amortiguar el impacto reducir el
choque y todas estas son reacciones de
equilibrio y de hecho hasta podemos
observar los constituyentes de estas
moléculas lo que hay aquí tenemos un
carbono un carbono y un carbono
tenemos 123 oxígenos aquí 123 oxígenos
aquí y 1 2 y 3 oxígenos dos hidrógenos
dos hidrógenos y dos hidrógenos
ahora pensemos en qué pasaría si de
repente agregaremos muchos iones de
hidrógeno a la sangre que hoy vamos a
ver qué pasa si agregamos iones
hidrógeno iones hidrógeno pues si
agregamos más iones hidrógeno
y esto de aquí incrementa bueno de hecho
vamos a ver esto primero si agregamos
iones de hidrógeno y no obtenemos estas
reacciones de equilibrio de aquí
entonces el ph de la sangre bajaría el
ph de la sangre de crecería y si lo
hacemos suficiente terminaría con
acidosis pero afortunadamente tenemos
este sistema tampón así es que si
aumentamos la cantidad de iones de
hidrógeno el principio de lecha tellier
nos dice que estas reacciones de
equilibrio se van a mover hacia la
izquierda
entre más iones de hidrógeno tengamos es
más fácil que uno de esos iones de
hidrógeno choque contra el bicarbonato
de la forma correcta y se forme ácido
carbónico y entre más ácido carbónico
haya en la sangre menos probable es que
el dióxido de carbono reaccione con una
molécula de agua para formar más ácido
carbónico así es que si agregamos iones
de hidrógeno
iones de hidrógeno de más se van a
absorber con las moléculas de
bicarbonato así es que estas dos
reacciones de equilibrio se van a mover
hacia la izquierda por lo que no vamos a
tener un efecto tan grande en el ph y de
la misma forma si agregamos alguna base
si agregamos una base en lugar de que el
ph suba y tb acá los ix el lugar lo que
va a suceder es que la base va a
absorber a estos iones de hidrógeno
generalmente si eso pasara si subiría el
ph de la sangre pero si tienes pocos
iones de hidrógeno entonces va a ser más
difícil que reaccionen formando ácido
carbónico y por lo tanto el equilibrio
se va a ir hacia la derecha y más
dióxido de carbono se va a transformar
en ácido carbónico el cual a su vez se
va a transformar en bicarbonato por lo
que todo esto se va a mover hacia la
derecha
y hasta cierto punto va a poder reponer
los iones de hidrógeno que se llevó la
base que agregamos así es que lo que
tenemos aquí es un sistema tampón un
sistema que amortigua si le agregamos
muchos iones de hidrógeno a la sangre o
si hay una base que está absorbiendo
todos los iones de hidrógeno y este
sistema es súper importante para
nosotros es importante simplemente para
poder seguir vivos y bueno de hecho es
importante para cualquier mamífero